is montana in the midwest or out of the
Midwest nobody knows every state that's
not on the east coast or west coast
sounds like a Midwest State it's tennis
be a part of the Midwest
North Dakota South Dakota these are easy
because they're pretty much the same
things I hope I know where Iowa is I've
been there
Iowa I have oh boy wait is this a state
what is water this is water Iowa can be
any one of these I'm gonna guess this is
Iowa right there Iowa is right there
Ohio Ohio Ohio seems weird to me so I
just thought it was over here Illinois
is gonna be right here bingo Wisconsin
Wisconsin this is Wisconsin I'm pretty
sure this is Wisconsin I know it's kind
of close to the top I mean it's old Hoss
I think we share a border with Canada
okay so Minnesota's there and then this
is Idaho Idaho is there Idaho I'm
missing this year this looks like a
great spot for some potatoes so where it
is Indiana go I'm actually confused them
forgot about Indiana wait Missouri isn't
one of these is it I'm almost 100% sure
Missouri's a southern state of Missouri
I know this is Missouri because I met a
lot of wonderful people Nebraska one
Nebraska Kansas there no it's not it's
here Arkansas is that in this as most we
Westerners can attest West Coast people
and East Coast people know nothing about
the Midwest I feel like you couldn't
date a Midwestern ER and it would be
like okay I think one exception okay
that's that's fine this is really solid
the Midwest would be very happy with
this we didn't bite you to a meat raffle
a meat raffle oh boy what's ahead this
is really good all of them are correct
except for this one but in fairness
pretty similar there's no fix all the
people of Idaho and Iowa miss Leftwich
Zach's 5th grade geography teacher if
you're watching this do I have a seat in
here that's not even in the Midwest
you have plenty of stay cereal it's not
another way I'm a big fan of the Midwest
well you should come sometime and we can
show you around I don't think you guys
want me there why don't they just make
it a giant Dakota like look how big
Minnesota is I feel like they could have
just made one big Dakota the main
takeaway of this video is that nobody
does or Idaho is so Midwesterners if you
ever complain that nobody knows where
your state is at least you don't live in
Ida